these dumplings are made of real shrimp
meat
but instead of being farmed in water
tanks or rivers
this shrimp is grown in the lab by
singapore-based startup
shiok meats
[Music]
globally we are the only company working
on
cell-based shrimp and crab since we are
making this from the actual cells
to the dna level the nutrition as well
as the taste is exactly the same as the
original product
around the world startups like shiok
meats are racing to invent and improve
alternatives to traditional meat
production
which is often criticized for
environmental and ethical reasons
the advantages of using cellular
agriculture to make seafood is
that you don't need to set up
large-scale farms or
go into the oceans to catch these
animals for human consumption
so environmentally friendly there is
very less greenhouse gas emissions
or carbon emissions as well and is
animal friendly because we don't
slaughter the animals in large scale
[Music]
plant-based meats are already here
alternative proteins from home-grown
insects are on the way
and now with advances in technology
cell-based seafood could soon be coming
to a table near you
so ever since i've known i was always
intrigued by the human body so i wanted
to kind of know
how the human body works how does
digestion happen
how does blood flow how does the brain
work and all of that and
always imagine myself being in biology
this passion brought sandhya shruram
from her home country india
to singapore where she got a phd degree
in biological science
and co-founded two other tech companies
before starting shiok meats in 2018
i've been a vegetarian all my life for
ethical
more environmental reasons i just put my
skill for biology
and my love for food and my love for
sort of saving this environment and
doing my part in this world together
and said why not grow seafood using stem
cells
[Music]
cultured meat is not new in 2013
dutch professor mark post created the
world's first burger patty from cells
so far more than 60 companies have
joined this field
backed by increasing funding from
investors and the cell-based meat market
is projected to reach 140 billion
dollars in the next decade
cultured chicken developed by startup
eat just was approved for commercial
sale in singapore last december
a first for a cultured meat product but
while many companies are working on
cultured chicken
beef and duck meat shiok focuses on
seafood
so shrimp crab and lobster alone makes
about
150 billion dollars worth of market
share
in the world and asia is the largest
producer
consumer and exporter of these proteins
and it's well liked by all of us and we
consume a lot of crustaceans
so the process of growing cell-based
meat or seafood involves three main
steps
the first step is where you isolate the
stem cells from live animals
these are the source cells of any animal
sort of the
birth cell that can grow into any organ
and these cells
are then put into large scale tanks
called bioreactors
which are pretty much like a brewery but
instead of brewing beer it's brewing
meats and seafood
and we feed these cells with liquid
nutrients that convert these cells
into the actual tissue muscle fat
connective tissue
and real meat at the end of the day that
has the same taste
nutrition and eventually the same
texture and look as well
compared with farm seafood these
cultured versions are friendlier to
animals and the planet
shiok meat says growing cultured seafood
is also at least six times faster than
farming them
but it's pricey a kilogram of cultured
shrimp costs nearly a thousand us
dollars
the key reason the liquid nutrient
solution that helps the seafood to grow
is an expensive pharmaceutical product
used to make things like vaccines
when we started off the liquid nutrient
mix that we use to feed our
cells used to be pharmaceutical grade
because that was the only thing
available
out there but what we have managed to do
in two and a half years
is to swap out some of the chemicals
with plant extracts
or edible products that makes the food
more nutritious and delicious as well
and eventually our process
will involve 100 plant-based and edible
nutrients
and we are aiming to be at about 50
per kilogram by the end of this year
the company also faces another hurdle
how to make this novel
lab-grown food appealing to customers
we're looking forward to sort of
breaking the myths that are out there
and making people understand that this
is the future
and it's as safe for them as possible
and it's the same meat and seafood that
they're used to eating
shiok meats has raised over 20 million
dollars in funding
and plans to launch their products
within the next two years
yet it might still take years even
decades for cultured meat and seafood to
go mainstream
but sriram remains hopeful so our
mission
is to feed the 10 billion that we will
be in the next couple of decades
and the ever-growing population after
that as a consumer you walk into a
supermarket and you go to the frozen
aisle of meat and seafood
and you see everything from cell-based
meat and seafood to plant-based meat and
seafood
and a small section of conventional meat
and seafood
and that's sort of the vision for the
entire industry and for shipments as
[Music]
well
you